[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat sur france 24
consacrée au débat entre emmanuel macron
et marine le pen ce duel a lieu ce soir
à 21h heure de paris vous pourrez le
suivre bien sûr en direct sur nos
antennes sur france 24
emmanuel macron placé à gauche marine le
pen à droite 16 caméras une
climatisation à 19 degrés le débat est
soumis à des règles très strictes il va
durer deux heures et demie l'ordre des
thèmes a été tiré au sort comme le
placement des deux candidats ils
commenceront par le pouvoir d'achat puis
la politique étrangère la sécurité
l'immigration et enfin l'écologie alors
ce débat est il décisif peut-il faire
trancher les indécis on va revenir aussi
sur les grands thèmes de ce duel avec
nos invités j'ai le plaisir d'avoir à
mes côtés anita auxerre bonsoir soit un
éditorialiste à atlantico hauteur de
gerald gérald darmanin pardon les
secrets d'un ambitieux bienvenue à vous
en face de vous pierre haski bonsoir
chroniqueur des géo politique à france
inter bienvenus pierre dans ce débat
nous avons également avec nous paolo
levi paulo bonsoir soin de l' agence de
presse italienne en deçà et puis en face
de vous marque end velde bonsoir vous
êtes journaliste d'investigation et
chroniqueur à la tribune auteur de
l'emprise la france sous influence et
c'est au seuil on va tout de suite à la
plaine saint denis justement retrouver
marie szuster notre envoyé spécial elle
est devant les studios où le débat va
avoir lieu dans quelques instants mari
bonsoir on attend bien sûr les deux
candidats qui devraient qui devrait se
montrer dans pas très longtemps
peut-être un quart d'heure vingt minutes
oui c'est ça on attend les deux
candidats marine le pen emmanuel macron
qui devrait se présenter ici devant les
studios de la plaine saint denis aux
alentours de 19h30 alors ici tout est en
place bien sûr je suis à l'extérieur de
ce plateau de près de 1000 mètres carrés
où pas moins de 300 techniciens se sont
affairés pour installer ces deux bureaux
qui se feront face à face chaque
candidat bénéficiera à l'intérieur de ce
bureau d'un moniteur qui leur permettra
d'avoir un oeil sur le décompte de leur
temps de parole ce bureau sera à 4 m
attends à deux mètres cinquante de
distance il sera deux mètres cinquante
de distance l'un de l'autre ce bureau
sera à quatre mètres de distance de
celui des deux journalistes qui ont été
rigoureusement choisis également par les
candidats de ce soir lors de ce débat
nous avons d'une part léa salamé pour
france télévisions et gilles bouleau
pour tf1 cet exercice pour eux sera très
contraint puisqu'ils n'auront pas de
droit de suite c'est à dire qu'ils ne
pourront pas posées aux candidats des
questions enterré sur leurs déclarations
antérieures au débat en régie nous avons
également un réalisateur didier froehly
qui lui-même sera supervisé par deux
autres réalisateurs chacun étant le
soutien d'un des candidats il y aura
d'une part philippe ballard en soutien à
marine le pen et et et jérôme revon
pardon en soutien à emmanuel macron
chacun fera en sorte que les
négociations autour des plans de coupe
soit bien respectée car je vous le
rappelle ceci a été très négocier aucun
plan de coupes sur le candidat lorsqu'il
boit de l'eau par exemple lorsqu'ils
regardent ces fiches mais n'a été
autorisé par les équipes de campagne sur
le plateau pas moins de seize caméras
filmeront le débat et sept autres ont
été installés en cas de panne tout a été
négocié je vous le disais y compris la
température du plateau négocier à 19
degrés l'intensité des lumières sur le
plateau les places ont été attribuées
nous verrons marine le pen à droite de
l'écran et emmanuel macron à gauche de
l'écran ses passes ont été attribuées
par tirage au sort par l'art comme l'ex
csa le theule la parole également a été
attribué par tirage au sort c'est marine
le pen qui devrait ouvrir le bal de ce
débat et le chlore et puis je vous le
disais tout à été millimitré pour se
tenir ce débat qui devrait se dérouler
durant
2h30 2h30 au cours desquelles les deux
candidats pourront opposer leur
programme
ce débat sera donc très aseptisé au
départ mais il ne faut pas oublier que
ce débat est aussi un grand rendez vous
dans cette élection présidentielle et
les électeurs attendent du spectacle ils
attendent très certainement les
punchline que pourront s'échanger les
deux candidats à la présidentielle et
qui peuvent faire balancer basculer une
élection
merci marie pour tous ces détails on
voit bien dans que ce débat est
extrêmement codifié un débat macron le
pen qui est une sorte de match retour
bien sûr pour les deux candidats après
leur duel de 2017 en 2017 il était 16 5
millions à l'avoir regardé ce débat
florilège de ce premier match 2017 avec
nos confrères de france télévisions avec
léo peschard
du calme et de la clarté l'un comme
l'autre ont le même objectif ce mercredi
faire tout linverse donc du débat de
2017 qui avait été confus et tendu vous
êtes à plat ventre en permanence devant
l'allemagne puis devant les puissances
d'argent aux différents les banques à
plat ventre et madame le président a
rappelé avant je suis debout mais pour
être debout je n'ai pas besoin de salir
vous en permanence vous salissez
représente l effet tranché vous salissez
les uns et les autres madame le pen les
proches de marine le pen l'admettent
cinq ans plus tard leur candidate était
trop agressive c'est quoi les erreurs à
ne pas commettre dans ce genre
d'exercice hervé voilà ça sert à rien
réagir outre mesure on est là pour
défendre un projet des idées il te mets
un carnet être prise la république
deuxième écueil que chacun tentera
d'éviter les approximations pour l'une à
la condescendance pour l'autre comme
lors de ce moment du débat où les deux
candidats évoque les entreprises sfr et
alstom chercher dans vos dossiers vous
seriez
8 et en faire des fusions acquisitions
ça vous savez très bien le n ya aucun
problème vous êtes en train de lire une
fiche qui ne correspond pas au dossier
que vous avez cités il y en a un qui
fait des téléphones et l'autre ça n'a
rien à voir il fut à la fois des
turbines et du matériel industriel
attention complexe de supériorité
l'équipe d' emmanuel macron et
conscientes de ce risque s'est pas de
l'arrogance que d'interroger dans un
moment aussi important que le débat de
la présidentielle pour savoir ce qu'il
ya derrière la cape de banalités
derrière laquelle marine le pen s'est
drapé depuis de trop longues semaines
c'est un panier de 2 de son propre aveu
marine le pen était arrivé au débat
fatigué et insuffisamment préparés mais
ça existait juste avant l'euro juste
avant que l'euro devienne notre monnaie
physique en france eh oui quant au
spectacle global offert aux
téléspectateurs on ne devrait pas
revivre l'ambiance de 2017 y avait une
violence qui était pas rentrer et qui
était même exprimé là je pense qu'ils
ont décidé tous les deux de se calmer
elle d'être compétentes crédible en se
mélangeant pas dans ses notes dans ses
fiches et des havres un ton
présidentiable et lui de ne pas sembler
arrogant ou professoral ou donner des
leçons madame le pen jusqu'à la dernière
seconde le duel avait été électrique il
ya cinq ans un spectacle télévisé
s'était alors projet contre projet ce
mercredi il sera aussi question du pi
dans les manuels macron
alors 1 et à auxerre commence peut-elle
faire mieux marine le pen qui elle dit
d'ailleurs qu'elle avait raté ce fameux
débat 2010 et je crois que tout le monde
est d'accord là dessus elle a raté son
débat et je crois que ça n'avait
beaucoup traumatisée pendant un certain
temps même quelques mois voire années et
puis tout d'un coup elle est repartie et
là on peut dire qu'elle est ce n'est
plus la même marine le pen qu'en 2017
j'ai pas quelle est la vraie m'enfin là
on a vu une marine le pen calme posé
apaisé pendant toute la campagne donc de
toutes façons ce débat ne ressemblera
pas à celui de 2007 elle fera mieux très
différents c'est évident qu'elle fera
mieux alors comment est-ce que emmanuel
macron va réagir ça c'est la grande
question parce que lui il n'a pas
débattu depuis longtemps et ce qui sera
désarçonné est ce que il va la prendre
de haut c'est le problème qui est posé
je dire ce qui va il va jouer les
professeurs est ce que c'est moi j'ai
fait voici mon bilan ça va être
compliqué ça va être plus compliqué pour
lui marquer nouvelle vous êtes d'accord
il avait l'avantagé de la nouveauté en
2010 est emmanuel macron il n'a plus cet
avantage c'est vrai et il a ce bilan à
défendre sa dette son défi des faits
relevés c'est même le gros risque pour
un manet macron c'est de se retrouver
dans la posture de l'homme du passif
pour tron une célèbre expression du
débat à mitterrand jusqu'à dans les
années 70 donc pour emmanuel macron il
ya quand même un enjeu important pour ce
débat là notamment sur le bilan
certes marine le pen a plein de points
de fragilité on sait que ce soit sur sa
connaissance des dossiers sûr on va en
parler sûrement ses postures au niveau
international notamment par rapport à la
russie mais dans le même temps emmanuel
macron a aussi des points de faiblesse
notamment sur les dossiers industriels
sur les questions des polémiques qui a
pu avoir pendant la campagne je pense
notamment à mckinsey elle pourrait
attaquer là dessus des choses qu elle
refuse énormément dans l'opinion
publique et donc il a un enjeu quand
même aussi d'image par un bureau à
l'ensemble des françaises c'est à dire
de se retrouver empathique notamment je
pense soit là ou gilet jaune ou à des à
des portions de population française qui
sont quand même dans un fort
ressentiment à l'égard des manuels
macron le lait bio va beaucoup regardé
ce débat en italie sont france 24
notamment mais écoutez il ya
certainement un intérêt parce que c'est
quand même un extraordinaire exercice
démocratique un moment très très
important aussi pour pour l'europe se
débat et il ya un côté aussi finale du
coupe du monde parce que c'est unique en
europe parfois on aurait presque envie
d'avoir l'écran géant au champ de mars
pour aller le voir tous ensemble en tout
cas c'est un grand moment en de
communion
républicaine et je pense que ça va être
vraiment très suivi certainement par
toute la presse italienne parce que oui
kruth 1 et le choix des français
dimanche va avoir un impact direct sur
l'avenir de toute l'union européenne
donc c'est très important c'est un débat
qui dépasse cela la dimension purement
nationale mais qui a une envergure
européenne pia skieurs justement
européenne sur les thèmes le premier
thème sera le pouvoir d'achat le second
la politique étrangère ce qui est tout
de même plutôt bien placé alors que
alors manifestement emmanuel macron ont
souhaité qu'il soit même premier plein
pour j'imagine valoriser sa position de
chef de l'état oui et puis pense que
c'est un des points faibles évidemment
de
marine le pen à cause de sa proximité
avec vladimir poutine pendant toute
cette période y compris souvient elle
était allée voir poutine au kremlin en
2017 pendant la campagne électorale et
c'est là-dessus qu'aujourd'hui en pleine
guerre d'ukraine évidemment elle est
prise à rebours par par l'actualité par
aussi par l'émotion des français c'est
vrai que
majoritairement les français comme les
autres européens ont été bouleversés par
les images d'ukraine et que marine le
pen a fait volte-face tout d'un coup
pour se retrouver en position de
partager l'émotion des français en
condamnant très vite l'intervention en
russie mais de leur d'ukraine mais elle
et elle est obligée aujourd'hui de
justifier toutes ses positions d'avant
et c'est là que manuel macron un sorte
de boulevard parce qu'elle a fait
beaucoup de déclarations qui peuvent
aujourd'hui lui être reproché on va
écouter justement emmanuel macron sur
sur l'europe
la bataille que nous menons n'est pas
simplement
parce que le projet d'extrême droite qui
efface à celui que je défends en votre
nom a beaucoup ici présents c'est un
projet
ils se cachent maintenant ils plus
ambiguë mais c'est un projet de sortie
de l'ordre pour ou contre l'europe c'est
un référendum pour ou contre l'union
européenne a affirmé emmanuel macron
anita auxerre où il va y avoir de
l'europe dans ce débat vous pensez aux
vraisemblablement ma foi je ne crois pas
que cette élection soit un référendum
pour ou contre l'europe
marine le pen ne veut plus sortir de
l'europe donc elle ne veut elle ne veut
plus sortir de l'euro donc l aele il ya
un acquiescement de sa part de l'europe
et de la politique européenne et
emmanuel macron porte le flambeau
européen depuis toujours donc je ne
crois pas que ce soit vraiment l'enjeu
de ce débat c'est ce que lui dit parce
qu'effectivement europe des nations
versus union européenne vous ne pensez
pas on sait progressisme contre le
conservatisme contre mondialisme enfin
ces clivages en fait sont
un d'actualité en 2022 justement à ce
point sa fin je sais pas ce que
m'inspire raskin moi j'ai la pression le
problème c'est que ça va être plus
compliqué aujourd'hui qu'en 2010 est de
prouver une certaine manière de montrer
que marine le pen veut sortir de
l'europe parce que le
effectivement il a raison de dire que
son projet c'est la paralysie de
l'europe puisque ce qu'elle appelle
l'europe des nations c'est le contraire
de la manière dont l'union européenne a
été conçu et a fonctionné jusqu'à
présent mais c'est évidemment beaucoup
moins évident beaucoup moins visible que
lorsqu'elle s'est pris les pieds dans le
tapis en 2017 sur la sortie de l'euro
vais sortir de l'euro qu'elle n'a pas su
expliquer et où il y avait quelque chose
de clair là
elle dit pas qu'elle veut sortir mais
elle veut changer la nature de l'europe
et de fait elle a un projet qui est de
en phase avec celui de viktor orban le
premier ministre hongrois qui est de 2
ans gros de couper les ailes de
bruxelles et de faire de cette europe de
l'intergouvernemental et non plus disons
une option fédéralise hantent ce qui est
celle de d'emmanuel macro mais il peut
l'attaquer sur son projet européen
justement puisque manifestement emmanuel
macron veut démasquer marine le pen
c'est un peu le langage qu'elle utilise
le point d'heure
2 les clivages être sûrement sur le
terrain stratégique parce que à marine
le pen souhaite sortir du commandement
intégré de l'otan donc elle précise pas
de l'otan entièrement maîtres du
commandement intégré de l'otan je
rappelle que c'est sous nicolas sarkozy
que la france est revenue dans le
commandement intégré de l'otan ce n'est
pas le choix d' emmanuel macron il avait
évoqué l'otan avec des paroles très
fortes en 2019 on se souvient de la mort
cérébrale de l'otan donc
c'est peut-être sur ce niveau là que le
débat va se polariser sur la question
ukrainienne tiers en gros quelle
stratégie secure et de sécurité pour
l'union européenne et pour la france
tout simplement olivier sur l'europe
peut-être aussi en totalité l'option
militaire ou pas elle a évoqué
l'allemagne également dit qu'elle ne
souhaitait plus de coopération militaire
avec l'allemagne ont écouté le chemin de
l'europe est comme une bicyclette on
peut pas faire du sur place parce que
quand on fait du surplace on risque de
tomber donc il faut absolument
avancer avec marine le pen en or est
dans la meilleure des hypothèses
un blocage dans le meilleur sinon pas
parce que par moments on peut même
craindre qu'elle l'a démonté cette
europe 70 ans de construction commune
mon avancement dans la main aujourd'hui
face aux menaces qui nous incombe de des
autres super puissances comme la chine
comme la russie on a un impératif
en europe c'est celui de rester le plus
possible unis main dans la main
fraternelle et solidaire parce que sinon
on risque de se faire dévorer dans cinq
ans par la chine par les états unis par
la russie aujourd'hui le patriotisme
j'ose dire passe aussi par une forme de
défense de notre modèle européen et
pensé par exemple de façon très concrète
aux sanctions contre la russie c'est une
question qu'on discute ces jours ci
l'europe a fait front commun ça a été
assez extraordinaire a fait preuve
d'unité et marine le pen pendant toute
la campagne présidentielle n'a pas fait
mystère de son opposition à ces
sanctions là donc si la france pays
fondateur de l'union européenne devaient
en est envoyé à bruxelles une présidente
com lepley peine les sanctions
européennes seraient bloqués ça
marquerait une victoire extraordinaire
pour vladimir poutine au coeur de
l'europe donc c'est vraiment un péril
majeur qu'on est en train de
vivre aujourd'hui narcos je pense que
emmanuel macron va davantage tâche et de
la pousser dans ses retranchements à
propos des relations franco allemand
parce que elle veut remettre en cause un
certain nombre de points de cette
relation et ça quand même ça ça parle
beaucoup plus aux français que l'europe
en tant que concept ne comprennent pas
toujours très bien dire on remet en
cause la coopération franco allemande
dans un certain nombre de duras certain
nombre de points je crois que ça c'est
interpelle beaucoup et à skis ski et ski
est très paradoxal c'est que tous les
sondages d'opinion depuis très longtemps
mon cas une grande majorité des français
qui sont attachés à la construction
européenne y compris dans l'électorat de
du rassemblement national tient un grand
paradoxe parce que la majorité des
électeurs du rassemblement national ne
sont pas d'accord avec le programme du
rassemble nationale sur l'europe jusqu'à
présent c'était un sujet marginal
on ne votait pas en fonction de la
politique étrangère l'ukraine a ramené
ce sont les chaînes ramener les choses
de manière plus central sans doute pas
déterminante mais plus central donc la
question de ce débat c'est est ce que il
ya des gens qui vont se dire voilà
est-ce qu'on peut prendre le risque de
la de remettre en cause tout remettre en
cause mais les relations avec nos
voisins l'allemagne effectivement mais
pas seulement et un certain nombre de
deux choses qu'on considérait comme
immuable voilà la paix en europe et
cetera qui ne le sont plus
les siens sur la question de l'ukraine
et de l'opinion française il faut quand
même je mets un truc mais un bémol mais
les les enquêtes d'opinion à fin mars
début avril montrait justement
qu'aujourd'hui le sujet numéro un des
français c'était le pouvoir d'achat les
plus l'ukraine donc il faut enfin il
faut être dedans de ce point de vue là
parce que le pouvoir d'achat avec les
conséquences de la guerre bien
évidemment sur la question de l'énergie
question du gaz et ça là pour le coup
marine le pen c'est son cheval de
bataille c'est son cheval de bataille
elle peut mettre peut-être emmanuel
macron devant certaines de ces
contradictions où anita hausser
recommande peut-il défendre lui le
pouvoir d'achat face à marine le pen qui
en a fait le coeur effectivement de sa
campagne puisqu'elle parle de baisse de
la tva à 5 5% sur une centaine de
produits de première nécessité sur le
carburant là pour le coup il a son bilan
il a le bilan et les statistiques
montrent bien que le pouvoir d'achat
même s'il a peu augmenté il a augmenté
sous le quinquennat de d'emmanuel macro
alors c'est pas le ressenti forcément
les français ce n'est pas leur santé
vous bien dans le sentier leur sens avec
l'inflation aujourd'hui est ce qu'ils
ressentent justement
bien sûr que non mais je veux dire il
est à l'action il est aux manettes le
gouvernement réagit avec contre le prix
de l'essence contre le prix de l'énergie
il ya le bouclier énergétique
il ya la baisse imposée de
deux prix du carburant
il a des arguments à opposer à à marine
le pen en revanche quand le pouvoir
d'achat ça englobe aussi les retraites
des retraites a roulé dessus
effectivement alors qu'yves âge je pense
que là il va y avoir un vrai débat sur
le montant des retraites pas seulement
sur l'âge de départ parce que sur l'âge
de départ ils ont bougé tous les deux
marine le pen disait retraite à 60 ans
elle est elle est allée se retraite à 62
ans avec la retraite pour la retraite à
60 ans pour les les jeunes qui
travaillent enfin les gens qui ont entre
les carrières longues qui commence à
travailler à l'âge de 17 entre 17 et 20
ans emmanuel macron quand la retraite à
65 ans il a bien compris que ça que ça
ne marchait pas donc il apparaît trop
pédaler il a rétropédalé et surtout il a
ouvert la porte aux négociations
ce qui évidemment ça ne va pas décréter
que les retraites c'est à partir de 65
ans c'était pas ça je veux dire il ya
une dégressivité il ya déjà des
négociations par branches enfin tout ça
se met en place progressivement en tout
il y aura un face à face sur cette
question pas leurs épaules les vies de
la retraite de la retraite bien sûr
c'est là la grande promesse manqué de
d'emmanuel macron dans son premier
quinquennat et donc ça va être
certainement un thème de débat ensuite
sur le pouvoir d'achat pour quand même
pas oublier du quoi qu'il en coûte parce
que c'est quand même quelque chose
d'unique en europe qu'a mis en oeuvre un
prétendu président libéral qui n'a été
libérale du tour ce cas là et qui a été
rendue possible aussi grâce à un acquis
fondamental de 2020 et de l'heure et je
pense que ça va passer dans l'histoire
européenne c'est l'adoption du plan de
relance de 750 milliards d'euros qui a
été approuvé en juillet 2020 à bruxelles
et qui marque pour la première fois à
l'introduction en europe due forme de
mutualisation de la dette et donc de
fraternité européenne et c'est grâce à
l'europe si emmanuel macron a pu faire
le quoi qu'il en coûte ne l'oublions
jamais il a fait quoi qu'il en coûte
avant avant de rappeler deux choses
s'emboîtent parfaitement une dent louisa
et c'est un grand résultat de la france
je suis désolé il a obtenu la
mutualisation de la dette c'est vrai
mais ils avaient décrété et mis en
oeuvre le quoi qu'il en coûte au moment
de l'achat
et même avec les gilet jaune il avait
lâché dès les vannes avec 15 milliards
d'euros louis g7 remarque de balès qui
peut convaincre encore emmanuel macron
sur cette question du pouvoir d'achat et
par exemple récupérer une partie de
l'électorat de jean luc mélenchon alors
il a avancé 10 ans il a repris plusieurs
expressions de jean luc mélenchon il a
parlé de planification écologique il
venir il a il avait faim et voilà il a
envoyé plusieurs signaux vers
l'électorat de jean luc mélenchon mais
après elle apparemment il a été entendu
puisque les sondages on monte à oui mais
parce qu'une bonne partie de l'électorat
de jean luc mélenchon reste de gauche et
donc non on ne goûte guère il n'arrivait
de de l'extrême droite au pouvoir donc
là mais sur sur emmanuel macron et
est-ce qu'il va réussir à convaincre je
ne crois pas c'est ce que je disais à
l'instant c'est l'électorat qui va voter
là emmanuel macron ça sera contre marine
le pen avant tout
et notamment sur l'électorat de jean luc
mélenchon il ne je ne pense pas que les
autoroutes mélenchon attendre des des
déplacements des avancées de d'emmanuel
macron sur le plan social ou économique
ce sera le vote anti anti le panis au
front républicain
pierre haski ben 2010 est en tout cas
ils fonctionnent pas sur un plan
institutionnel n'y a pas d'automatisme
et ya pas de même les partis ne se
prononce pas mais jean-luc mélenchon est
resté très ambigu dans sa dernière
intervention en revanche il fonctionne
dans les têtes c'est à dire que à la
dernière minute la question et comme l'a
dit marc c'est que des gens de gauche
est ce qu'ils peuvent porter la
responsabilité historique de laisser
arriver au pouvoir une l'open certaine
manière parce que c'est c'est le fond de
la question
on est dans un débat et c'est là que que
tout on dit toujours les débats ne
change pas la position des gens n'a
jamais non pas les 3% de l'indicé c'est
ça que la journée dans une cour une
conjoncture qui est un petit peu
particulière c'est que d'abord le
résultat du premier tour a montré trois
blocs et non pas 2 avec mélenchon qui a
un rôle d'arbitré donc son électorat ses
vingt et quelques pour cent sont les
arbitres de ce second tour et puis un
gros bloc d'abstentionnistes du premier
tour est ce que ce sont les mêmes
abstentionnistes le deuxième tour est ce
que il ya moyen d'en ramener
quelques-uns au deuxième tour parce que
tout d'un coup il ya un sens de la
gravité de la situation qui était moins
présent dans la campagne électorale on a
eu une campagne électorale escamoté qui
a été très banalisés et très médiocre
par rapport à ce qu'on a pu connaître
dans le passé et donc tout ça ce sont
des inconnus dans ce débat et la
question n'est pas tellement du vote
d'adhésion mais de d'arriver à
convaincre les gens de voter contre
contre l'autre ça parce qu'il ya tout
sauf marine le pen et puis aussi accro
ya les deux il ya les deux et
franchement on
ne sait pas qui fait qu'ils enfin là
combien il son audience hier de
l'électorat mélenchon
votre est votre et macron un tiers très
le pen il reste quand même beaucoup
beaucoup d'indécis est encore une fois
est-ce que ça va se traduire par des
abstentions ou est ce que il va y avoir
un vote un rejet de l'un ou de l'autre
en tout cas ces jeunes qui ont voté pour
jean luc mélenchon très jean luc
mélenchon sont très très sensible à la
question de l'écologie et l'écologie n'a
pas été beaucoup question pendant cette
campagne en revanche emmanuel macron a
fait un long discours à marseille sur
l'écologie il affirmait d'ailleurs que
la politique qu'il mènera dans les cinq
ans à venir sera écologique ou ne sera
pas on écoute le 24 avr elle
c'est un référendum pour ou contre
l'union européenne
[Applaudissements]
le 24 avril
c'est un référendum
pour ou contre l'écologie
le 24 avril elle c'est un référendum
pour ou contre notre jeunesse
le 24 avril c'est un référendum pour ou
contre notre république
oui le 24 avril
peut-être le point de départ d'une
nouvelle époque française et européenne
c'est une espérance
celle du climat celle de l'ambition
oui
nous gagnons
et alors ce sera à nous de faire
autrement encore tous ensemble
vive marseille
[Applaudissements]
c'est tout de même une préoccupation
tardive 1 que la question d'écologie
puis là il veut renverser la table
emmanuel macron après cinq ans au
pouvoir c'est porter ce type de discours
c'est un discours de campagne on a on a
eu une nouveau monde en 2017 on l'attend
toujours donc voilà bon moi je j'ai
écouté ce discours comme un discours de
campagne électorale
c'est pas un discours pour ou contre
l'écologie après l'élection n'est pas
une élection pour ou contre l'écologique
vous rencontre l'europe pour ou contre
la république c'est un discours
politique
ces jeunes qui tout de même souhaite
plus d'écologie ceux qui ont voté pour
jean luc mélenchon ouais enfin là c'est
pourquoi on l'a dit c'est plutôt des
effets d'estrade je m'assure que
justement dans le cadre d'un débat face
à marine le pen ces mêmes effets
d'estrade pourrait avoir une efficacité
moi ce qui me frappe quand même sur cet
entre deux tours qui est quand même
assez étrange c'est que marine le pen on
l'a rappelé tout à leur avait fait une
campagne de premier tour qui était
plutôt une campagne de second tour ou à
la il passait totalement la question la
préférence nationale qui était en son
programme les les angles les plus
compliquées de son programme et au
moment du passage au premier tour elle a
souhaité rassembler mais elle a eu aucun
ralliement sur sa personne et au
contraire les journalistes les médias
mais également les responsables
politiques qui ont posé des questions
sur son programme qui est un programme
finalement d'exclusion c'est qu'on a les
images en direct il a justement les voir
arriver marine le pen annonce ne sont
pas des images en direct mais on les
aime tant ils sont lisses vont vraiment
bientôt arriver on les aura d'ailleurs
ces images en direct pas le lévy
l'écologie elle devrait attirer les
jeunes est ce que c'est le cas aussi
d'ailleurs en italie mais oui écoutez
c'est certainement une question certes
entre les deux candidats moi j'ai été
très étonné quand j'ai entendu dire à
marine le pen que l'écologie c'est pas
du tout la priorité de son mandat duquel
le dis très ouvertement un l'a dit
l'autre jour à la presse emmanuel macron
seces c'est sûr et certain que son
quinquennat n'a pas été n'a pas répondu
aux promesses qui l'avait fait pendant
la campagne de 2010 est d'ailleurs la
france est condamnée a été condamné
justement pour n'avoir pas respecté les
engagements dans le cadre des accords de
paris sur le climat donc c'est clair que
c'est insuffisant pour l'instant et
voilà ce discours du pape et nous laisse
bien et serré pour l'avenir pour
l'instant ça est son bilan écolo a été
assez moyen pierre haski l on se
souvient tout de même deux mecs de
planètes great games était ce grand
raout internationaux au moment où donald
trump était sortie de l'accord sur le
climat a effectivement on a l'impression
qu'il y avait un affichage plutôt fort
au départ
oui il ya eu il ya eu plusieurs moments
d'affichage la convention citoyenne a
été également un moment fort qui s'est
terminée d'une manière ambiguë
puisqu'ils s'étaient engagés à reprendre
toutes les propositions créé il ya 2
après pas tout et voilà c'était un peu
compliqué mais le paradoxe est que tout
le monde est d'accord pour dire que
l'urgence climatique et la etc et on a
les deux candidats j'allais dire les
moins écologique mais en tout cas qui ne
sont pas les plus à l'est plus dix ans
sur le sujet qui se retrouve au deuxième
tour parce que marine le pen c'est
c-zéro emmanuel macron il prend des
engagements que que la suite ne tient
pas donc on comprend la frustration des
jeunes qui se disent mais c'est notre
génération qui va subir et et alors il
ya eu ce débat par exemple qui était
totalement surréaliste sur le fait que
étant donné que c'est les plus âgés
qu'ils avaient
qui ont été les seuls à donner
majoritairement emmanuel macron en tête
il ya eu comme ça cette rumeur dans
l'optique en disant interdisant au lieu
de voter puisque
le ils prennent des engagements qui ne
qu'il ne viseront pas que ce soit sur la
retraite ou sur le climat donc ces
voiliers de cette question elle suscite
énormément de d'agitation de confusion
d'apc voilà et on verra ce billet de
contradictions quand même oui mais on
verra ce que sera ce débat là dessus
parce que vous n'avez pas le premier je
crois que c'est l'un des derniers c'est
le dernier ces derniers tellement plu
dans cette population le dernier le nez
grâce d'ailleurs c'est l'avant dernier
ce
qu'il faut noter quand même c'est que
emmanuel macron à fermer fessenheim et
deux ans après il annonce la la
construction d'un certain nombre de
pères de petits op r pour
pour produire de l'électricité
marine le pen elle elle voulait
carrément rouvrir fessenheim mais les
faits sont là dessus sur le nucléaire
ils sont assez d'accord censé d'accord
en revanche il ya une telle
contradiction dans l'opinion française
les éoliennes tous les autres pays
européens ont fait des parcs éoliens en
haute mer il y à une contestation
je ne sais pas s'il est justifié ou pas
en france en rien empêché la
construction d'ailleurs voilà qui a
empêché la construction d'éolienne
marine le pen veut même des boeufs venir
les éoliennes enfin je veux dire on est
bourré de contradictions dans ce domaine
en tout cas ce débat ne portera
peut-être pas tellement sur l'écologie à
l'immigration vous disais que c'était le
dernier thème alors francs pour le coup
les clivages sont très importants par le
lévy j'imagine qu'on en parle beaucoup
en italie de la problématique migratoire
dont justement le programme de marine le
pen à rappelle un peu matteo salvini
enfin vous connaissez sarkozy en italie
oui complètement elle veut boucler les
frontières et mais aujourd'hui est la
grande question l'a vu ces derniers dix
ans on l'a vu avec toutes les crises
successives
avec la guerre en syrie et même après en
fait nous sommes tous sur le même bateau
en europe est la vraie question
aujourd'hui concerne plutôt les les
frontières extérieures de l'union
certainement pas celle interne et après
aussi il ya une vraie question est qui
concerne le développement des pays
voisins limitrophes notamment de la
bande sud de la méditerranée pensons par
exemple à la libye qui aujourd'hui est
devenu un vrai trou noir
et donc les dix ans cette approche très
nationaliste de marine le pen c'est un
petit peu comme à l'époque de ducobu où
on pensait de résoudre au niveau
national une question qui est
aujourd'hui va résolus de façon plus
large à l'échelle pertinente qui est
l'échelle ça c'est plus clair emmanuel
macron marc endeweld comment se fait-il
que l'immigration ne soit plus vraiment
le vrai clivage ou est-ce qu
effectivement emmanuel macron c'est le
vrai clivage est ce qu'il va en faire le
vrai qu'il va ce soir dans le débat moi
je pense qu'il va reparler également de
la question de l'islam il l'a déjà fait
là il ya quelques jours sur la question
du voile par exemple même parfois en
prenant des positions diamétralement
opposée à celle qu'il avait prise il ya
quelques mois donc bon ça c'est sur le
plan des symboles bien évidemment mais
moi ce que je pense la une des
difficultés est manal macron face à
marine le pen par exemple sur les
questions migratoires ça va être de
pouvoir expliquer aux français le peu de
résultats qu'il a pu avoir dans sa
politique vis-à-vis je vous interromps
parce qu'effectivement on à l'arrivée de
marine le pen donc à la plaine saint
denis là où se trouvent ces en banlieue
parisienne pour ceux qui ne connaissent
pas là où se trouve justement le studio
où va avoir lieu donc ce fameux débat
qui va démarrer donc je le rappelle à
21h heure française
c'est dans un peu plus d'une heure dans
l'un une heure et quart
marie schuster est d'ailleurs sur place
pour france 24 marie ont on va écouter
marine le pen sereine comme depuis le
début de cette campagne je crois que
l'enjeu
et d'expliquer aux français mon projet
le vrai parce que j'ai entendu et lu
beaucoup de choses qui ne correspondait
pas du tout à ce que je leur propose
donc ce soir j'aurais deux heures et
demie pour qu'il connaisse la vérité du
projet pour tous les français que j'ai
conçu
prépare de manière particulière quand on
affronte le même adversaire cinq ans
après c'est pas le même adversaire
puisqu'il a été cinq ans au pouvoir ce
qui n'était pas le cas la dernière fois
marie my sister vous êtes sur place pour
nous donc arrivé de marine le pen on
attend encore emmanuel macron qui n'est
jamais le
oui tout à fait marine le pen vous venez
de le voir vient d'arriver aux adam dans
ce studio de la plaine saint denis elle
avait le sourire elle a salué tous les
membres de la des directions de france
télévisions et tf1 qu'il l'attendait ici
nous attendons maintenant emmanuel
macron nous avons déjà vu arriver un
petit peu avant l des soutiens de marine
le pen jordan bardella et est déjà dans
les locaux des soutiens de d'emmanuel
macro également comme françois bayrou
alors marine le pen maintenant devrait
rejoindre sa loge où elle devrait
préparer son intervention
pour ce débat qui devrait avoir lieu à
21h emmanuel macron devrait arriver
d'ici quelques minutes également pour se
préparer lui aussi en loge alors
quelques précisions sur la technique
commence cette soirée vraiment là où la
ville ça roule c'est maryse avant un
plein nous l'avait dit au début de la 2
missions on n'a plus beaucoup de temps
mais vous restez avec nous toute façon
vous savez pendant toute la soirée elle
veut dire la vérité et race qui sait ce
qu'elle a dit marine le pen il y avait
deux choses intéressantes dans ce
qu'elle a dit d'abord sur sa sérénité
qui qui tranchait avec son agressivité
on l'a vu tout à l'heure de 2017 et puis
la deuxième chose c'est elle dit c'est
pas le même homme qui en face de moi et
même d'un bilan est donc là on voit bien
que il ya déjà les positions de départ
du débat
elle va l'attaquer surtout que le
premier thème et le pouvoir d'achat
elles valent à taper l'attaqué sur son
sur son bilan elle va essayer de le
faire passer pour l'homme du passif face
pour reprendre cette formule il a quand
même quelques hobby voilà lesquels
enfin c'est ce qu'on a dit tout à
l'heure c'est à dire de quoi qu'il en
coûte et les mesures oui contre contre
l'inflation et qui vaille est obligé de
poursuivre marc endeweld vous l'avez
trouvé effectivement plus sereine en
2010 est souriante elle a intérêt à dire
avant le débat on verra bien au moment
de débat
elle va avoir à mon avis du mal sur le
plan personnel à
dialoguer et qui est manal macron parce
qu'ils ont ils ont ils ont pas les mêmes
qu'on est un ressort discursif il ne
parle pas de la même manière il ne
maîtrise pas de la même manière les
dossiers et ça pourrait très bien a
amené une certaine irritation d'un côté
comme de l'autre vous allez dire ça à
peu mais elle a l'arrogance reprochée mn
alors qu'on peut revenir au galop comme
lala également la compétence la
compétence du côté de marine le pen donc
dans les deux cas pas retrouvé les mêmes
défauts qu'il ya ça quand on pourrait
retrouver les mêmes défauts qu'il ya
cinq ans et en même temps il faut que ce
soit une sorte de spectacle louis la
mise en scène est saisissante on voit on
a vu une rentrée
marine le pen dans la dans l'arène comme
les footballeurs qui rentre voilà dans
le stade en plus c'est saint denis à
côté du stade de france c'est vraiment
final ça c'est une constante c'est aussi
un
extraordinaire exercice démocratique
aujourd'hui il ya d'autres grandes
puissances qui voudraient remettre en
question notre modèle souvenons nous
toujours de qu'est-ce que c'est
important un tel débat et que la chance
que nous avons alors vivre en démocratie
mais des macros arrive justement est
plaine saint denis on va voir les images
en direct
le voilà
l'arrivée d' emmanuel macron donc marine
le pen on a vu est arrivé il ya quelques
minutes
emmanuel macron arrive à l'instant donc
la plaine saint denis c'est l'endroit en
banlieue parisienne où se trouve sous le
thème le studio où va avoir lieu ce
débat débat donc il y aura lieu je le
rappelle aux téléspectateurs à 21h heure
de paris que vous pourrez voir bien sûr
en direct sur nos antennes de france 24
on les écoute emmanuel macron il me
semble qu'ils répondent à des questions
de journalistes
avec brigitte maquereau ou ses livres il
est là mais
voilà il était accompagné de brigitte
macro comme vous voyez
on n'entend pas et on n'entend pas de
réponse marie un petit mot sur cette
arrivée marie schuster sur place
oui alors vous le voyez encore peut-être
derrière moi emmanuel macron vient tout
juste d'arriver également dans ses
studios de la plaine saint denis il est
accompagné de sa femme brigitte macron
il a longuement salué les directeurs de
france télévisions et tf1 qu'il
l'attendait aussi à l'entrée de ce
plateau un peu plus tôt il a été précédé
par marine le pen qui s'est dit sereine
emmanuel macron s'est montré souriant
face aux personnes qui qu'ils l'ont
saluée et qu'il a longuement salué nous
attendons maintenant ce débat entre
emmanuel macron et marine le pen les
deux candidats doivent et aubin et on va
l'écouter tout de suite marie louise a t
on les écoute prêt pour un débat qui
doit nous permettre à l'un et l'autre de
d'expliquer nos idées nos projets pour
la france de clarifier aussi tout ce qui
doit l'être de parts et d'autres
monsieur le président est ce qu'on se
prépare d'une façon spécifique quand on
affronte la même adversaire
cinq ans plus tard d'abord je crois
qu'on se on est conscient de
l'importance de ce moment
j'ai aussi à répondre de tout ce que
nous avons fait durant les cinq années
qui viennent mais non je crois qu'ils
rien de spécifique faut essayer de le
faire de la manière la plus précise et
honnête qui soit voilà
quelques instants
allez un mot de conclusion il nous reste
une minute paulo les villas vous
reprenez la métaphore sportive la
seconde mais oui complètement et c'est
un débat décisif pour la france et pour
l'avenir européen aussi anita auxerre
tous les deux exemples lui donner une
image apaisée de leur personne et net de
la perspective de ce débat pierre haski
je pense ça sera un débat très vif entre
celui de 2017 et il y aura des dizaines
de millions de personnes elle regarde et
c'est effectivement là je rejoins paulo
c'est un grand moment démocratique
markkanen si je reprends la métaphore
sportive je pense que les deux
protagonistes vont jouer en contres
plutôt dans le débat qui vont le débat
plutôt qu'à la tacc encontre photo call
attaque merci beaucoup en tout cas
d'avoir été avec no mercy anita auxerre
merci pierre haski merci paulo paul levy
merci marc n 2 devaient d'avoir
participé à cette émission merci à tous
de nous avoir suivis rester avec nous
parce que évidemment la formation
continue il y aura une spéciale édition
spéciale qui va précéder ce fameux débat
donc débat entre marine le pen et
emmanuel macron à 21h ce sera aussi sur
france 24 reste m
[Musique]